[Musica]
ciao sono luciana delle donne
ciò che mi avete chiamata per il mio
cognome però approfitto per raccontarvi
la mia storia
questo è un cappotto rigenerato che però
vi racconto dopo di che si tratta
intanto sono felice di potervi
raccontare una bella storia che è la mia
vita le mie vite perché in realtà ho
vissuto in tanti mondi diversi e mi
sembrano veramente vita e diverse
staccate però meritano di essere
raccontate e soprattutto possono essere
un esempio concreto per incoraggiare e
tante altre donne
tanti altri ragazzi tante altre persone
perché è un'esperienza che dimostra che
si possono fare anche cose impossibili
nella mia prima vita mi sono occupata
soprattutto di pil prodotto interno
lordo
nella seconda parte in quella attuale
invece di bill che poi vi spiego anche
questa dopo la l'idea è quella di
raccontare questa storia qui con voi
oggi perché è frutto di sacrificio
tenacia ambizione fatica stanchezza
addirittura un giornalista su vanity
fair
quando ho scritto un articolo ma ha
fatto una domanda che cosa ti manca di
più in questa seconda erica e io ho
detto due cose il silenzio e il sonno
perché ho bisogno di stare un po in
silenzio in questa mia seconda vita è
tutto molto molto molto stressate e
quindi ho bisogno di raccoglierli in
silenzio ma torniamo alla prima vita
torniamo al pil
torniamo a vecchi modelli vecchi modelli
di economia che non funzionano più
soprattutto dopo il 20 20 quel famoso 20
20 che aspettavano per cambiare il mondo
ci ha cambiato il mondo in realtà è il
negativo però quindi tornando al al mio
progetto legato al pil al mio progetto
al primo progetto di vita
io ho creato la prima banca online in
italia lo capo dei canali innovativi di
importantissime banche in italia quindi
mi sono occupata per oltre a 22 anni nel
mondo della finanza di creare strumenti
utili ai dipendenti della banca i
clienti ai promotori finanziari
diciamo che la banca la prima banca
online multicanale in italia l'abbiamo
creata noi l'ho creata io con il mio
team di oltre 250 persone quindi diciamo
che è stata una esperienza importante
perché abbiamo creato
abbiamo fatto da apripista in un mondo
dove la banca era grigia e triste e
tutta dell'impiegato di banca invece noi
poi con sharon stone che girava questo
computer diceva adesso la banca ce l'ho
io a casa mia era una testimonianza
un'esperienza importante perché faceva
un importante passaggio oggi siamo tutti
i computer izzati digitalizzati
ormai abbiamo una relazione così potente
con il mondo uno a tanti che ricordare
la prima banca on line italia quasi mi
fa sorridere però e questa è
un'esperienza importante che io ho
vissuto perché ha potuto aiutare un
altro nuovo gruppo di persone a fare
cose diverse che generassero il bill che
benessere interno lordo
qual è la definizione di benessere per
ognuno di noi è diversa diversissima
ognuno dei suoi valori valori spesso
intangibili e che nessuno mai misura
monitora o fa attenzione io dico sempre
perché mi piacciono le metafore io dico
che dare e darsi è la nuova frontiera
della ricchezza
quindi io faccio volontariato da oltre
12 anni e il lavoro praticamente gratis
in questo progetto perché è fantastico è
fantastico donare e vedere le persone
felici e una felici ma anche all'inizio
tristi perché mettono in discussione i
loro principi loro stile la loro
filosofia e io e come se gli facessi
togliere i loro occhiali e gli facessi
vivere un gli facessi vedere un mondo
diverso un mondo che non hanno mai
neanche esplorato perché da noi
io ho due vite ma mi hanno attraversato
la vita tantissime persone tantissimi
ragazzi studenti della luiss
l'università della repubblica dominicana
con il quale stiamo formando i formatori
per aprire altri laboratori simile al
nostro a santo domingo ma anche donne
che si sono avvicinati alla nostra
esperienza
parliamo del mondo della detenzione che
è il cuore di tutto il nostro progetto
ma io parlo anche di tutte le altre
persone che ci sono state vicino perché
abbiamo avuto persone
donate e hanno creato assistenza e
consulenza gratuita alla nostra onlus
abbiamo tante persone che hanno
accettato e hanno scelto di condividere
questo nostro percorso
noi che cosa facciamo una cosa
semplicissima
io prima mi occupavo di innovazione
tecnologica oggi mi occupo di
innovazione sociale noi nel mondo
dell'innovazione sociale avevamo bisogno
di inventare qualcosa di facile di
semplice e di veloce e così abbiamo
pensato di realizzare dei gadget
personalizzati dove le aziende scelgono
di sostenere il nostro progetto
attraverso un approccio di marketing e
di comunicazione sociale che rimane nel
tempo l'oggetto e tante persone fanno
questi video queste consulenze questi
webinar con dietro a una bellissima
scrivania
ecco io adoro mostrarvi la nostra
biblioteca d'autore questo è il mio
ufficio e questo è il nostro la nostra
biblioteca virtuale
a me piace chiamarla così dp la teca
d'autore chiedo scusa
e a me piace chiamarla così perché è un
modo per dimostrare il lavoro vero che
viene svolto da oltre 12 anni in
contesti di estrema emarginazione ed
estremo disagio perché
la detenzione deve cambiare il modo di
esistere e di essere noi ci siamo
non so perché io abbia scelto in questa
seconda vita
questo pezzo di mondo però avevo
intenzione di dimostrare che si
potessero fare cose belle
in questi luoghi abbandonati
ecco perché abbiamo creato questa scala
dei valori che un po rappresenta i
gradini di benessere che noi cerchiamo
di far risalire piano piano alle persone
e soprattutto alle persone abbandonate
ti metto gli occhiali così vi vedo bene
l'idea è quella di dare tangibilità
questi valori intangibili cioè il
benessere che cos'è il benessere a
tantissimi tasselli e quello che noi
volevamo fare era dimostrare proprio che
nel carcere attraverso anche dei dati
statistici che parlano in maniera chiara
che il lavoro nelle carceri abbatte la
recidiva dell'ottanta per cento mentre
chi non lavora in carcere e commette
nuovamente reato alla fine della
detenzione e diventa un costo per la
comunità quindi oltre al danno è un
costo che sono circa 60mila euro l'anno
questo significa che fare del bene fa
bene a tutti quindi era importante che
noi riusciamo a far risalire un gradino
di benessere alle persone che hanno
commesso degli errori alle persone che
non hanno ingranato la marcia giusta
perché spesso accade che hanno bisogno
soltanto di girare la chiave
soltanto di credere in se stessi l'idea
è quella di andare al monitorale che
cosa generiamo nella nelle persone e
questo diventa un valore diventa un
modello di economia rigenerativa perché
noi rigeneriamo la persona attraverso
l'utilizzo degli scarti tessili noi che
cosa facciamo noi andiamo a recuperare
nell'ambiente tessuti che altrimenti
genererebbero inquinamento sappiamo che
il settore della moda il secondo paese
al mondo il secondo settore che genera
inquinamento quindi è importante da
parte di tutti acquisire la
consapevolezza e prendere l'impegno che
fare bene fa bene a tutti e che bisogna
dare e darsi perché la nuova frontiera
della ricchezza chiedo scusa se lo
ripeto ma è importante perché sono
messaggi che noi raccontiamo sempre alle
donne in carcere noi le donne le
facciamo vivere nella bellezza
nell'eleganza gli diamo la possibilità
di studiare l'inglese la tecnologia c'è
la sala palestra la sala lettura abbiamo
creato una maison in carcere dove ci
sono ambienti bellissimi e soprattutto
loro attraverso la cultura riescono a
crescere ea diventare consapevoli per
loro ma soprattutto anche per i figli
noi abbiamo praticamente creato una
social accademy perché noi abbiamo
bisogno che più persone copino il nostro
progetto lo facciamo costantemente
quotidianamente è una cosa che ci piace
molto fare
e quest'anno la fondazione con il sud ci
ha dato una
aiuto importantissimo per accelerare
questa fase di ricerca in collaborazione
con le università perché ci vuole anche
un approccio accademico scientifico per
le cose che facciamo perché è giusto
dare visibilità e autorevolezza a tutto
quello che facciamo noi ma anche non
solo in carcere noi lavoriamo per
esempio nelle sartorie sociali di
periferia ne abbiamo tante sparse in
italia è importante perché noi diamo
allora il nuovo vediamo la materia prima
che di cui hanno bisogno
noi lavoriamo soprattutto per rigenerare
quindi o chiudo la mia biblioteca
d'autore perché qui ci sta la storia di
tantissime donne tantissime persone che
credono che bellezza ed eleganza possa
cambiare lo stato delle cose
provateci anche voi grazie